qui est pour vous le plus grand
animateur français de tous les temps
en france pensez-vous non non non non
non non mais je pense pas non mais
de tous les temps si vous êtes dans le
top 100 en tout cas j'ai pas la carrière
que je méritais je suis d'accord à
attendre pour moi et je le dis ici ce
soir jean vous jure que c'est vrai je
parle sérieusement sous le contrôle de
beinheim de kenny a conservé
guillaume aux siennes et de et raymond
c'est vrai j'ai eu johnny et on le
pensait un mathieu de lambeaux a fait
pour moi partie du top 5 des animateurs
les plus talentueux de toute l'histoire
de la télé et je ne rigole pas
[Applaudissements]
on
est passé à sale et passa
ses passes à sa demande et
lui je lui ai déjà dit je vous jure que
c'est vrai on a déjà eu cette discussion
alors on dit la vérité on dit tout un
jour j'étais avec mathieu on a une très
grosse discussion et je vous dis la
vérité je dis tu est pour moi le
meilleur je vais même dit tu es au
dessus de moi
que je dis tu sais ce qu'ils te manque
je vous jure que c'est vrai
le mental le talent est là bas mais le
physique il à la répartie là il a tous
les trajets le seul truc c'est le mental
est fascinant c'est vrai que c'est ce
que tu es d'accord pas parce que je
pense que vraiment je vous jure que
c'est vrai pour m e marc mathieu
mirassou drum je pense qu'il faut un
mental d'acier je ne rigole pas mais je
ne rigole pas je suis tout
le temps que les caractères est
sous-estimée et je rigole pas tu as
raison je pense que c'est c'est là que
ça s'est joué dans les mémoires
longtemps mais tend le bras qui tremble
ce qui se lèvent pas
incroyable non mais ça sert il me l'a
dit il m'a dit c'est dommage parce que
voilà les sens je lui tire déjà ils
t'ont arrêté tpm people étaient partis
en dépression non non non
mon père sauvé holla holla holla on l'a
rattrapé
dont le retour ou la ramasser à la
petite cuillère j'étends maxime qualité
c'est un accès
pour leur a fait des mauvais c'est légal
on est en train d'aller au devant de
gros problèmes
mon chéri non mais je trouve qu'on les
admire sachez vous franchement j'aime
mais
rien ne nous fait peur aux deux cas vous
unit c'est marrant parce que on disait
toujours avec de petits groupes
de jeunes et juste avec le
petit guillaume c'est le mec est là sur
le truc mais à propos de nous on se
disait le gars forcément parfois des
peurs des craintes d'eads et des failles
rien ne transparaît swiss ski dès qu'on
arrive sur le ring on se dit on va
perdre rien ne pense pas c'est quoi ta
femme et mon chou c'est quoi ce produit
de cochonou savoir de quoi logique une
couille
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je n'avais et benjamin c'est vrai que
pour être un très gros est un très bon
bein brin jaloux d'hôpital a
vraiment de vie la vérité mathieu vous
dire je pense que samba telecom
et leur tombait sous
le sens
[Applaudissements]
c'est un pari soleil
mais sa taille
mais cette année c'est
incroyable
non je vais arrêter
maintenant genre cheap show mais honnête
je ne mens jamais abbas alors à dirai la
vérité mathieu est de loin le meilleur
chroniqueur que j'aie jamais rencontré
il va vite il va très vite prêt à une
répartie incroyable il expérimente aux
savoirs revanche même pas quand il est à
la tête d'une émission il lui manque il
ya il faut que les il faut que la balle
reviennent et malheureusement quand il
est devant il lui manque quelque chose
donc je pense pas qu'il soit du tout
dans top 5 des animateurs mais dans le
top 1 et le numéro en tant que
chroniqueur je le pense sincèrement
alors il a tout faux
parce que
pour les émissions genre tu vois quand
j'ai fait ce stade je t'ai vu les
émissions vous faut lire un prompteur
lancer des invités bref elle génère avec
les autres voilà là j'avoue je suis
nulle et isa
c'est vrai que la générosité vous êtes
le contraire fait tout à faire là dedans
il est très bon ben jama et julhes
toutes ces émissions comme ça les au vol
c'était ma chance va annoncer ça m'amuse
pas du tout ça m'intéresse pas aux
revanches comme pour les émissions de
toutes les émissions où
la rationalité et pas seulement belle
chose que d'acheter tout à fait ma place
beaucoup plus d'ailleurs que benjamin je
sais que je salue
mais beaucoup plus là mais cyril le mec
il est parti l'an dernier qu'une tête
comme ça a dit attendez moi je vais
faire ma vie que les terrains il est
revenu ici un an après la batterie tient
au téléphone était encore plein fouet
les policiers
sa médiocrité personnel
vous du tout non les progrès des
sabbatique pour voyager sauf que c'était
comme idée j'ai pas aller très loin chez
ford où tu as vu ça va toujours les bons
jeunes joueurs
[Applaudissements]
non moi j'avais quitté me souvenais
qu'on avait fait le zoom en premier il
voulait dans la police il voulait faire
j'en ai
rencontré un commissaire a pour le coup
magnifique alors gay jeunes manifestent
gens parlent cette langue du cul pour
moi déclare sûr que c'est un commissaire
qu'est ce qui s'est passé et c'est vrai
ils m'ont dit en fait on pourrait
éventuellement mais ce serait dans les
bureaux parce que tu es trop vieux pour
te former
tu vas passer comme ça j'ai pas vous
retrouver dans la bac nuit comme ça au
bout de trois minutes à mi voix m
mathieu sais pas me servir d'un flux
d'actualités de bras je sais pas voilà
donc cela il veut ils n'ont pas voulu me
former donc les portes dans les bureaux
dans les bureaux ça me saoulait nord
d'accord pat réceptionniste donc en fait
vous avez essayé d'être policier oui
c'est l'image animateurs
coloris
différents c'est complet les données le
net et vous avez été également
conférencier aujourd'hui quel est votre
avenir
comme ça non mais battue est excellent
je suis très heureux du sérieux ou stand